jessie suggested this idea of figuring
out if you want to date a guy just based
on his instagram explore page i was at
dinner with a friend adding friends on
instagram usually guys will give me
their phone to add myself on instagram
and the search page is always where the
explorer is so before i go ahead and
search for myself i'll just take a quick
glance at their explorer to see you know
what kind of stuff they look at and then
i'll go ahead and add myself social
media algorithms know you well and it's
so scary but i have three guys for you
actually and i have a bunch of posts
that are randomly selected from their
instagram explore pages so i'm gonna
have you look through them and then
you're gonna decide who you wanna go on
a date with just based on that sound
good excited sounds good cool
hey i'm leland hey i'm dennis what's up
i'm jack what are you expecting today
what am i expecting so other than other
than finding the love of your life
that's the goal yeah i mean i'm
expecting you know maybe some i don't
even know what guys look at like cars do
you guys think like cars watches
hoes
i know no other things that guys do so
cars watches that's the only three
things that guys are i've always been
the type of person that's looking for
like a long-term relationship never
looking for something casual so based on
their explorer i would want them to kind
of be like a wholesome person outdoorsy
things that they do some like wholesome
hobbies like cooking this is like i
think even better than seeing what they
look at is just seeing what like they
subconsciously are at the depths of
their very soul you know what i mean
guy number one fire away first
impression ah it's a little weird
oh okay this is a really cute okay this
is this four goldens okay this is this
is a plus one
basketball
how to crossover like kyrie all right
basketball fan i also like basketball
i'm not like a huge connoisseur but
that's fun next one girls okay cool
girls is that a is that a good sign bad
sign i mean i prefer
guys feeds not have girls yeah but it's
not always his fault yeah it's not
always his fault because he follows he
has girlfriends yeah sometimes
according to my explore page i pay a lot
of attention to women and a bunch of
jack dudes i saw like one woman on your
feet it may have been curated yeah all
right i'll give him a pass on this one
if i could speak to my 18 year old self
i would say ah this is like basic woke
life advice i kind of like this that
means he's like trying to like better
himself yeah but it's so like cliche
it's so
all right here we go all right this is
like the weird stuff right here's a
girl's korean guy with some korean words
and he's like in oh oh here it is okay
so it's a screenshot of a youtube video
okay of a topless guy i don't know
what's going on
all right so this one was the really
jacked woman
the gym okay so this is another vision
so yeah i feel like this is like also
humor that i can't really relate to as
much
[Laughter]
all right next one
and going like that
this is really cute all right so so how
are we feeling about this guy okay so i
feel like him and i have a very
different sense of humor you get along
in terms of the wholesomeness in terms
of self-improvement and exactly yeah and
dogs
yeah i just didn't find any of these
like particularly like it didn't really
entice me to kind of like want to watch
more so he's probably like in his 30s
because he's getting these inspirational
quotes
i could be just a very precocious person
i'm dirty let's move on to the next
section
the guy number two is vastly different
i'm excited this one's like food i'm a
big foodie there's like sushi all right
okay let's go one by one this is like
cooking in a wok ooh i actually watch
these kinds of videos they're like it's
so impressive how quickly they cook this
looks like it's like thai food wow that
looks amazing i'm salivating it looks
good so this is something that you would
see yourself watching yeah like if it
popped up on your feet you would sit
there yeah because this is like street
food so i'm always curious like kind of
like how they make street food this is
cool okay this is also i think that
might be chinatown it's in london but
it's like a dr uh what's it called
chinese lion dance so maybe they're
chinese
oh my god sushi
all right so it's just like
all different plates of sushi i don't
eat that much sushi nike running shoes
okay so this guy is definitely a runner
ooh wagyu steak i love wagyu you can
tell she's such a booty she's such a
foodie oh sushi and wagyu looks amazing
love it well he's cultured he is i think
it depicts my hobbies well i think it's
hard for someone's explore page to
really accurately represent the actual
person right a lamb chop sandwich that
looks so good
okay so this guy might like cooking oh
maybe he'll cook a good meal for me okay
do you cook
i cook so guy too i definitely vibe with
a little more i feel so he's got a lot
of food that i like in terms of how
interesting his posts are i feel like i
would want to watch these a little bit
more than guy one's videos yeah cool
feeling the vibe here feeling the vibe
[Music]
all right guy number three okay so this
looks like this guy has one interest
which is sheba's
okay the first one is a cocktail
it looks like he might have like he's a
little fancy next one oh this is so cute
with glasses yeah sheba with glasses on
reading a book next one is food yummy
ball of
pork oh that looks good okay so this
person might also be a foodie oh it's a
baby corgi
super cute and this one is like is it do
you know what this like i don't remember
okay so this person might be into anime
this person just really likes cute
things yeah i mostly just use ig for
like hobbies oh that i think i think my
ig explorer page is very not
representative
super cute baby cat pounces at the
camera and that's it it's just purely
just cute
mochi ooh i love mochi oh she's good
llama bread you probably actually have
like an interest in cooking or baking if
you're watching this video is that true
i cook a lot yeah i think this guy
needs more interest than just pets yeah
maybe they're just like you know in
their free time they just want to look
at cute things and get their mind off of
you know whatever they're doing yeah
right i would expect maybe like two to
three pet posts per every 50 per 15
minutes yeah i think so i think that's a
good number two or three i didn't think
it was very representative yeah
i thought mom was kind of on point
[Music]
so now that we've seen all three of them
how are we feeling about each of the
guys so guy number one he seems like he
has a lot of interest but i think i
don't really vibe with his sense of
humors as much because i'm the type of
person that likes to like send like all
my reels and like all my tick tocks to
you know that person so i would want
them to be able to understand me you
want someone that's kind of similar guy
number two okay so i think this guy
obviously loves food wagyu beef sushi i
also love that i'm big foodie he is an
active person runs cycles this guy's a
pretty solid maybe solid maybe pretty
good guy number three mostly all pets
some cooking so mostly like dogs and
cats seems like a wholesome guy i feel
like cat people like are kind of
different from the internet a little bit
different from dogs just different so
i'm more of a dog person i'm very
allergic to cats so i'm also allergic to
cats okay okay go team yeah or do you
have a dog or cat i don't i don't know
no pet
no
i thought your page was full of shibas i
don't know why
hello everyone this is jessie hi
you can scoot more this way
jesse you picked leland as the winner
so yeah
congratulations they don't feel that
instagram
represented them properly
that's true so how do you think that it
misrepresented you or didn't represent
you enough i like i also like food
yeah i still don't know why there's so
many animals on my explore page
this is the fun part so i'm gonna leave
you guys to yourselves for a little bit
and you're gonna go off on a little mini
date and we'll just talk for a bit and
then we'll come back later and we'll do
a little check-in and see what you guys
want to do after that sound cool sounds
good cool
where are you taking her on a date she
loves michelin star restaurant
so it might have to be
one of those do you think this is a good
way to find a date i think it could be i
don't i think i think there's so much
more you need to know about a person but
it could be a good start you guys look
really good together
[Music]
you